ciao a tutti mi chiamo mogliano 30 anni
ultimamente mi capita spesso di
guardarmi dietro sia per controllarmi il
culo che per osservare la strada che ho
fatto nel corso degli anni dieci anni fa
era un ragazzo in sicuro non credevo che
ci potessero realizzarsi e molto spesso
mi sentivo solo a volte mi chiedo cosa
accadrebbe se potessi tornare indietro
nel tempo e incontrarmi in che modo
potrei dare una mano quel ragazzo in che
modo potrei aiutarlo migliorare quali
sono le cose che gli direi per aiutarlo
ad affrontare al meglio un alice la
tavoletta del water rotta può sembrare
ancora tu non abbia imparato a sederti
successo che che c'è un cazzo ma tutte
uguale a me corte mi stanno sono molto
più amo più effemminato è molto più
giovane quindi mi stai dicendo che
corrono a tutti i bisogni assolutamente
è e dov'è l'altra parte della casa non
c'è a pil in questa topaia e dov'è la
pista del colosseo io qui vedo solamente
i campi mucche beh diciamo che per
vedere il colosseo dovreste avere dei
binocoli rakic se una lista dalla pace
perché vivo in borgata anche se è
rimasto così umili e nonostante tutto e
anche hollywood è riuscito a cambiarti e
che senso non è vinto un oscar
no però se ti interessa lo scaldabagno
rotto e la lotteria
non ho però vinto la lotteria
dell'amicizia che è quella che conta è
non è miss task un bel fisico lab
beh diciamo che no
una domanda che bello ma il cellulare
fichissimo si è la con 7 plus da apple
dopo qualche anno ha deciso di iniziare
a fare telefoni cellulari ma non e
pulsanti poi è l'ultimo modello no ne
sono usciti altri due a mamma quindi se
povero telo attento roger detto sono
sono ricco dove queens etico di sterno
hai un'ottima capacità polmonare no nel
cuore ora lo vedi questo questo qui è
instagram che è un nuovo social nuovo è
bello se avesse sempre per postare foto
si è per scovare ma come scusa perche
non è non è questo il punto comunque
quando un po stretta lui è il tuo
ragazzo mezzo vecchio ma che cazzo dici
mamma ma come vecchi ma non ti importa
che finalmente al futuro potrei essere
libero di essere te stesso quanti anni a
allora siete coetanei scusa a quanti
anni mi dai ben diciamo bene è molto
carino vero deve avere una bassissima
stima di se stesso per accontentarsi di
uno come te e tu quindi questa così
spiega veronesi fumo dalla marmitta non
faccio la revisione dei tre anni allo
specchietto distrutto sì però in realtà
lo rotto mentre cercato di parcheggiare
in va affiancata alla serata ho
strisciato mentre cercavo di
parcheggiare e anche l'altra sempre
mentre cercavo di parcheggiare smentiti
parcheggiare un cazzo cioè devi smettere
di fare così ci rimango male nella vita
maturerà in un sacco
non era da martino avere dei sogni
capirà che il modo migliore per coronare
i propri sogni è quello di svegliarsi
come questo sembra un incubo senza fede
vabbè che sta facendo il bambino dai
cioè quale l'unica cosa che mi rincuora
la cosa che al mondo esistono ancora
persone come steve jobs è morto michael
jackson un patto queste mie giusto una
ricevuta paolo villaggio 6 quito
margherita hack schiattata police ancora
non l'hanno trovato
speravo che non mi chiedessero hanno
trovato qualche mese fa degli
esploratori assunte della campagna un
[ __ ] cazzo che c'era ultimo per
fatto un incontenibile che è successo è
un fallito da goleador bile domani
ciascuno
non ho io devo capire dove nel corso
degli eventi
devo aprire un canale su youtube
dormi